[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على حضراتكم لا صوت يعلو على
طوفان الاقصى والحدث الرئيسي اللي بيشغل
اذهان مش بس الناس اللي موجودين في العالم
العربي والاسلامي في العالم كله لمحاوله
فهم ما يجري في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
المحتله انا بستيف اليوم استاذي استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه المرموق احمد يوسف مش بس
عشان يشرح لنا ما جرى ولكن عشان يساعدنا
على فهم ما قد يحدث ويترتب على طوفان
الاقصى صباح الخيرات معال الدكتور صباح
النور يا استاذ سيد ربنا يخلي حضرتك الحدث
مذهل والاسئله اللي متعلقه به كثيره جدا
هل ممكن استاذن حضرتك حضرتك في الاول بس
نبدا من نقطه الصفر لماذا تعتقد حضرتك ان
حماس في هذا
التوقيت قامت بهذه العمليه الضخمه طوفان
الاقصى لماذا هذا التوقيت
الان شوف حضرتك يا استاذ سيد
يعني قد يندهش البعض اذا بدات حديثي
بالقول بانه من المنظور التاريخي لا توجد
مفاجاه في ما جرى الذي اقصده بالمنظور
التاريخي فلسطين حاله نموذجيه
للاستعمار المشروع الصهيوني بدا منذ اواخر
القرن التاس يوضع موضع التطبيق مؤتمر
الصهيوني الاول اعلن هدف انشاء دوله
يهوديه على ارض فلسطين ثم بدا المخطط ينفذ
من خلال الهجره اليهوديه التي سهلها
الانتداب البريطاني واقام المهاجرون
البنيه التحتيه للدوله اليهوديه التي
اعلنت في
48 ثم استكملت اسرائيل احتلال اراضي
فلسطين بعد عدوان
س7 متجاوز في هذا كل مبادئ القانون الدولي
وحتى قرار التقسيم وكل هذا
الكلام التاريخ يعلمنا انه اي ظاهره
استعماريه يكون لها رد فعل يتمثل في
المقاومه في قوانين الطبيعه بتقول كل فعل
رد فعل مساوي له في المقدار ومضاد له في
الاتجاه فتعود او تعلمنا من التاريخ انه
كل فعل استعماري له رد فعل مقاوم ورد
الفعل المقاوم ده عاده بيبدا بدايه شديده
الضعف يعني لو تصورنا مثلا بدايه حرب
التحرير الجزائريه في اول نوفمبر
عشرات قليله من المجاهدين باسلحه قليله
جدا ولكن في خلال ثمان سنوات اذا بهؤلاء
المجاهدين رغم التضحيات الجسيمه يجبرون
الجيش الفرنسي يجبرون
فرنسا على الانسحاب من الجزائر التي كانت
تعتبرها
اراض فرنسيه فيما وراء البحار فهذا
النموذج المقاومه تبدا ضعيفه ثم تقوى شيئا
فشيئا نتيجه عوامل الايمان بالقضيه بينما
المستعمر بالضروره ليس على نفس الدرجه من
الايمان الحاضنه الشعبيه احيانا الدعم
الخارجي ثم ان مقاومه الاستعمار عاده
بلورت اساليبها الخاصه في النضال بحيث
يعني ظهرت لنا ظاهره ما نسميه بالحروب غير
المتماسه ثله اللي هي الحرب بين جيش نظامي
وقوه غير نظاميه والتاريخ بيقول لنا انه
ميزان القوه بين المقاومه والاحتلال بياخذ
في التصحيح شيئا فشيئا الى ان نصل الى
نقطه تزيد فيها تكلفه الاحتلال على عائده
وبالتالي يغير الاحتلال سلوكه ويسلم
باستقلال الشعوب المستعمره وفي بعض
الاحيان المحتل بتبقى عقليته مغلقه
وبالتالي لا يستجيب لهذه التطورات التي
تطرا على ظاهره المقاومه فتحدث له ضغوط من
الداخل تجبره على هذا كما حدث في فرنسا
عندما قتى الجيش الفرنسي بشارل ديجول الذي
تفاوض وسلم باستقلال الجزائر في
1962 او في حاله البرتغال في مستعمراتها
الافريقيه التي تشددت جدا في ظل نظام
الفاشي الى ان وقع انقلاب
1974 وغير النظام تماما وتم التسليم
باستقلال المستعمرات البرتغاليه اذا ما
يحدث في فلسطين منذ 48 وحتى لحظه تفجر
طوفان الاقصى هو حاله نموذجيه للخبره
التاريخيه عن تطور الظاهره الاستعماريه
وما يترتب عليها من مقاومه اذا ليست هناك
اي مفاجاه تاريخيه فيما جرى وجولات
المقاومه بين اسرائيل والفلسطينيين جولات
عديده من اول
انتفاضه البراق الى ثوره
1936 الى تفجر المقاومه المسلحه في
1965 الى الى الى وصولا مثلا معركه
الكرامه في
1968 الجولات العديده بين اسرائيل وبين
المقاومه الفلسطينيه انتفاضه الحجاره منذ
نهايه 87
وحتى يعني غزو الكويت في 1990 انتفاضه
الاقصى وبالتالي طوفان الاقصى هو حلقه من
حلقات صراع تاريخي
طويل لماذا الان لان اذا كنا نقول انه
ليست هناك مفاجاه تاريخيه فيما يحدث لماذا
الان انا اتصور ما يلي وقد يكون اجتهادي
ناقصا او غير دقيق لكن اتصور ما يلي لو
نتذكر يا استاذ سيد ما يجري في مسار
القضيه الفلسطينيه في الاونه الاخيره سنجد
اولا لاول مره هذه الحكومه شديده التطرف
يعني كل الحكومات الاسرائيليه طبعا مقتنعه
ب يعني حقها في فلسطين
و تقدم او تمارس كل الممارسات التي تتسق
مع هذا لكن مع الحكومه الاخيره التي طر
الحاليه التي طر نتنياهو الى القبول
بتشكيلها لكي ينقذ نفسه من ورطه المحاكمه
في قضايا فساد اظهر لنا وزراء من نوعيه لم
تعرفها حتى الحكومات
الاسرائيليه المتشدده من قبل بنفير وس
موتتش وهؤلاء الناس الذين ينادون علنا
بحرق القرى الفلسطينيه ويستخفون بكل
المطالب الفلسطينيه ويبالغون في الممارسات
التعسفيه شديده القسوه ونذكر اظن سموتريتش
هو اللي قال نحر قريه حوار كلها دي او شيء
من هذا القبيل ا تغول الاستيطان
في ظل هذه طبعا الاستيطان موجود من قبل ل
زعماء الاستيطان بالضبط في ظل هذه الحكومه
مزيد من تغول الاستيطان يعني الزياده
الهائله في الاستخ توضيع اوضاع الاسرى و
الفلسطينيين بالضبط الاستخفاف الهائل
بالمقدسات الدينيه سواء المسيحيه او
الاسلاميه وفي الاونه الاخيره عمليات
اقتحام الاقصى واخراج المصلين منه الادعاء
من بعض المستوطنين بان هذه المساكن التي
يسكنها فلسطينيون منذ لا اقول مش ليس
بالضروره من الاف السنين لكن منذ مئات
السنين ان هذه منازلنا الى اخره يعني ما
اريد قوله انه الممارسات الاستعماريه
الاسرائيليه في الاراضي الفلسطينيه قديمه
ولكنها بلغت في ظل هذه الحكومه مبلغا لم
تصله من قبل
وبالتالي لكل فعل رد فعل وكان من المؤكد
ان تفكر فصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه في ما
العمل في ظل هذا
الاستخفاف ايضا في الاونه الاخيره بدا
وكان مشكله القضيه الفلسطينيه هي كيف نخرج
التطبيع بين اسرائيل والدول العربيه لانه
في ظل هذه الحكومه لو نذكر في وقت من
الاوقات كان الشعار المرفوع الارض مقابل
السلام اعطونا اراضينا و يعني ننجز معكم
سلاما وكانت هناك تجارب سابقه التجربه
المصريه في
1979 التجربه الاردنيه في
1994 فكان المطلوب ان يطبق ذات المبدا
وفقا لاتفاقيه اسلو
1993 اتفاقيه اسلو مر عليها الان اكثر من
30 سنه الشهر اللي فات كانت الذكرى الط
ولم تحقق اي
شيء عندما تغلق
الابواب الدبلوماسيه
والسلميه طبعا لابد ان يعطي هذا دفعه
للوسائل
الاخرى بدلا من ان يعني يكون هناك زخم
للحديث عن الحل السياسي
نتنياهو يعني طرح الامر بمنتهى الصراحه لا
حديث على عن دولتين ولا عن مفاوضات عن
القضيه الفلسطينيه وانما الحديث كل طبعا
ولا دوله واحده وانما كل الحديث عن السلام
مع العرب وكان القضيه الفلسطينيه هذه نسون
منسي فطبعا في هذه الظروف لابد ان تتوفر
مقومات هذا العمل الجبار الذي حدث لما
نتذكر مثلا انتفاضه
1987 المعروفه بانتفاضه الحجاره ايضا متى
تفجرت عندما
بدا وكان النظام العربي يعني يتخلى ولو
نسبيا على القضيه الفلسطينيه في ذلك الوقت
كانت الحرب العراقيه الايرانيه التي تشغل
بال العرب عندما 87 ده كان في ظل وجود
جورباتشوف عندما بدا ان العملاقين يتفقان
علينا او يتفقان بصفه عامه وبالتالي شعر
الفلسطينيون ان قضيه ان قضيتهم تضيع ومن
هنا تفجرت انتفاضه الحجاره متى تفجرت
انتفاضه الاقصى بعد الزياره الشهيره لاريل
شارون او الدخول يريل شارون اقتحامه
للمسجد الاقصى فما اريد ق بالضبط ما اريد
قوله ان الظروف في الاونه الاخيره كانت
يمهد لهذا العمل الذي لا شك ان فصائل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وحماس قد اجادت
اخفائه او اجادت يعني سريته طبعا حضرتك
تعلم انه اي عمل من هذا النوع لابد وان
يكون سريا يعني ساعه الصفر يعني ولنا
تجربه في حرب اكتوبر وهي المقارنه بتفرض
نفسها بالضبط لنا تج حرب 6 اكتوبر وحرب 7
اكتوبر ومع فارق انه في حرب اكتوبر كان
لدى العدو معلومات انه ربما يكون هناك شيء
ما لكن كما نعلم في عمليات صنع القرار
ليست القضيه ان تكون لديك معلومات ولكن
كيف تفسر هذه المعلومات وقد فسرها قاده
اسرائيل بانها نوع من الاستنزاف المصري
لقدرتهم لانه ضمن عمليه الخداع
الاستراتيجي كما نعلم انه في سنه الحرب مر
مرتين القوات المصريه تستنفر وتقوم
بتحركات يعني تصلح لان تكون بدا 22 عمليه
تعبئه في العشره شهور التي سبقت الحرب
بالضبط بالضبط وبالتالي يعني في تلك المره
يعني قرا قالوا لا يعني هذا حدث من قبل
ولا توجد نيه في العدوان واضح ان اصدقائهم
الامريكيين كانوا
يشاركونهم في هذا يعني انا سمعت باذني من
ويليام كوانت الذي كان مستشارا للامن
القومي ايام حرب اكتوبر يعني قال لي انه
يعني وكان جديدا على مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي ان كل شيء كان يشير الى ان هؤلاء
الناس ينوون القتال لكن زملائه قالوا له
ما معناه يعني انت جديد علينا ولا يعني
تعرف حيل المصريين فهنا الخداع
الاستراتيجي شيء مهم جدا في حاله الوفان
الاقصى انا احسب قد يكون حساباتي غير
دقيقه لكن احسب ان الخداع الاستراتيجي هنا
تمثل في ان حماس اظهرت نوعا من التفاهم مع
حكومه نتنياهو ان هي لا تبادر بعمل مقاومه
او شيء من هذا القبيل وهنا اذكر
بعمليه اطلاق صواريخ من الجهاد على اسرايل
في مايو 23 مايو السنه دي ولم تشارك فيها
حماس بالعكس ده لما بعض المصادر
الاسرائيليه قالت هي حماس البتاع نتنياهو
دافع عنها وبالتالي يجب ان اعترف ان انا
واحد من الناس الذين قالوا يبدو ان حماس
قد كيفت اوضاعها لكي تحافظ على سلطتها في
قط انا تصوري انه هذا ده كان نوعا من
الخداع الاستراتيجي الذي ظهرت فوائده
بوضوح في عمليه الاقتحام التي تمت حضرتك
قلت كلام جميل جدا بس طرح برض مجموعه
كبيره من الاسئله فمش عارف ابدا بايها
يعني لكن لكن فهمت من حضرتك انه لو بتتكلم
على الحوافز او الاسباب اللي ادت الى
طوفان الاقصى اولا حرك بتقول ده ليس امرا
غريب بالنسبه ل يعني ارض محتله وهكذا شان
المقاومه يعني انما حضرتك بتقول في
التوقيت بقى سببين السبب الاول هو
الاستفزاز الاسرائيلي المستمر اللي وصل
ذروته مع الحكومه المتطرفه اللي بيقود
نتنياهو منذ اخر
2022 الامر الثاني هو ان قطار التطبيع
يسير وكانه لا توجد قضيه فلسطينيه صحيح
البعض بيقول انه احد الاسباب هي مح دوله
حماس نسف هذه محاولات التطبيع اللي ممكن
تتجاوزهم واشاروا تحديدا الى اصرار
الولايات المتحده واسرائيل محاوله التطبيع
مؤخرا مع طبعا المملكه العربيه السعوديه
مع تهميش القضيه فيبدو ان عاوزين يقولوا
انه هذا صعب ان يتم دون ان نكون في الصوره
هل حرك تتفق مع هذا التحليل يعني محاوله
نسف الرغبه الامريكيه في التطبيع مع بين
اسرائيل والسعوديه يعني هذا تحليل منطقي
بمعنى انني اوافق عليه ولا املك ادله
قاطعه على صحته انما عندما اضع نفسي في
موضع
الفلسطينيين انا عاجز حتى الان عن الحصول
على ادنى قدر من حقوقي ولدي منهج لدى
اسرائيل تقول فيه ان قضيتنا الاولى هي
السلام مع العرب وليست حل القضيه الفلس
ينيه من المنطقي جدا ان احاول لفت النظر
الى انه لا يا جماعه ده في حاجه اسمها
قضيه فلسطين فهذا تحليل في راي بالغ
المنطقيه لان لو ان قطار التطبيع استمر
هتكون النتيجه في النهايه هي تطبيع
اسرائيلي مع عدد يعتد به من الدول العربيه
مع زياده في تجاهل حقوق الفلسطينيين فان
قام فلسطيني او فصيل فلسطيني او فصائل
فلسطينيه بعمل مضاد لهذا العمل ليس يعني
بطريقه مباشره ولكن بعمل يقول انا هنا
هناك قضيه
تستحق
الاهتمام به وبالمناسبه هذا المعنى ورد في
مقاله الحقيقه رائعه للصحفي الاسرائيلي
اليساري جدعون ليفي نشرها يوم 8 اكتوبر في
هارس
وقال فيه اولا كلام يشبه الكلام الذي قلته
في اجابتي على السؤال الاول ده طبيعي ان
ده يحسن طبيع ا لكن اشار ضمنا انه يعني
انتم كنتوا معنيين جدا بالتطبيع وما الى
هذا ونسيتم
الاصل انا طبعا قبل ما اعدي النقطه دي
اسمح لي ان انا يعني اعرض وجهه نظر يعني
بغض النظر عن قناعتي بها البعض بيطرح سؤال
طب يقول طب وهي حماس منزعجه ليه التطبيع
بين اسرائيل والسعوديه اذا كان الموعود
بين قوسين هو انصاف الفلسطينيين بين قوسين
يعني
ا شوف حضرتك انا لا ادع خصوصا انه يقال ان
السلطه يقال وليس لدي دليل ولكن من مصادر
متعدده يعني لا تمانع في مساله التطبيع ما
بين اسرائيل والسعوديه ا ليست عندي
معلومات دقيقه انما عندما نقول ان السلطه
لا تمانع في التطبيق في التطبيع التبع فمن
المؤكد انها قيل لها اننا سنحصل لكم على
كذا وكذا وكذا انا تصوري طبعا مع كل
التقدير للنوايا التي يعني كانت تريد ان
اسرائيل تقدم تنازلات منذ بدا قطار
التطبيع في التسارع وحتى الان لم تقدم
اسرائيل اي تنازل ذي شان في القضيه
الفلسطينيه قراءتي للحكومه الاسرائيليه
انه طالما الحكومه الاسرائيليه الحاليه
باقيه لا يمكن ان تقدم تطبيعا تنازلا له
معنى للفلسطينيين اقصى شيء كان ممكن يحدث
زياده تصاريح العمل زياده المساعدات
الماليه زياده تصاريح البناء في
الاراضي الافراج عن بعض الاموال المجمده
الافراج عن بعض الاموال المجمده الى اخره
امور لا تمس جوهر القضيه الفلسطينيه
وبالتالي اتصور انه المقاومه الفلسطينيه
كانت
تشعر بهذا وانا اريد ان الفت هنا الى ان
موقف السلطه الفلسطينيه وعلى راسها الرئيس
محمود عب
من طوفان الاقصى موقف لافت لانه الرئيس
محمود طبعا لانه الرئيس محمود عباس معروف
انه رجل سلام وانه في وقت من الاوقات كان
ينتقد الانتفاضات الفلسطينيه لتقد حما
معنى انه في عمل ضخم كهذا العمل يتخذ هذا
الموقف
انه يشاركنا في تقييييم ان ما يجري يهدد
مصير القضيه الفلسطينيه والا ما كان قد
اتخذ هذا الموقف معال الدكتور تقدير حضرتك
طبعا احنا في تفاصيل كثيره لا نعلمها ما
زلنا يعني ونحتاج وقت يعني من بين
التفاصيل ديت ازاي حماس استطاعت ان تتملك
هذه القدرات الاستثنائيه في مباغت دوله زي
اسرائيل اظن ان ده هيحتاج وقت ان احنا
نعرفه كيف تملكوا السلاح كيف تملكوا هذه
التكنولوجيا التكتيك الى اخره انما اذا
تجاوزنا هذا السؤال اللي احنا محتاجين وقت
عشان
نعرفه اذا كانت حماس قامت بعمليه يعني غير
مسبوقه واكيد كانت تتوقع رد فعل غير
مسبوق تفتكر حضرتك انه حماس كانت بتراهن
على ايه وهي مقبله على هذه العمليه هي
تدرك انه اسرائيل ربما تدمر كل المنشات
الحيويه في غزه ربما تسعى لتدمير حماس
نفسها ا طبعا هذا سؤال مهم جدا ومنطقي
جدا لماذا تلجا حماس ومعها فصائل فلسطينيه
اخرى الى مثل هذا العمل الكبير الذي تعلم
ان رد فعل اسرائيل له سيكون مروعا هم
نفسهم نتنياهو قال ردنا سيكون مروعا
وسيغير خريطه الشرق الاوسط طبعا نسبنا من
حكايه تغيير خريطه الشرق الاوسط يعني
يتكلم على قده يعني انما انما يعني هم
كانوا يعرفون
جيدا رد الفعل الاسرائيلي لنجاحهم ا كيف
سيكون
وهنا اتوقف عند
يعني طرح سؤال متى يعني هنفترض ان عمل
حماس فيه مخاطره عاليه وفيه يعني توقع
عاقل لان العاقبه ستكون شديده العنف
وشديده القسوه وشديده التدمير السؤال الذي
اطرحه متى يلجا المرء الى عمل قد يراه
البعض غير رشيد يعني انت رايح تهاجم لي
مستوطنات اسرائيل ووالى اخره وانت تعلم
القوه
التدميريه الاسرائيليه ما هو القضيه اولا
انا صاحب قضيه وليه حقوق تم تجاهلها تماما
والنقطه بقى الثانيه دي اهم انني جربت كل
ما يمكن تجربته من وسائل دبلوماسيه لا
ننسى لا ننسى ان
الفلسطينيين قدموا تنازلات لم تكن تحلم
بها
فلسطين اسرائيل لكن لغه القوه بتجعل
اسرائيل تزداد عنجهيه يوما بعد يوم يعني
الفلسطينيين قبلوه
بانه اسرائيل موجوده كدوله بس نقيم دولتنا
في اراضي 67 اليس هذا تنازلا كبيرا طيب في
اتفاقيه اسلو اعترفوا بدوله اسرائيل رغم
ان اسرائيل لم تعترف بدوله فلسطين وان
كانت للامانه قدمت تنازلا تاريخيا عندما
اعترفت بمنظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه كممثل
لشعب فلسطين وهذا ضحد المقوله الصهيونيه
الشائعه ارض بلا شعب لشعب بلا ارض انما
الفلسطينيين اعترفوا باسرائيل في اسلو
واسلو وضعت يعني اطارا للحل هذا الاطار مر
عليه كما تفضلت 30 سنه سنه ولم يسفر عن اي
شيء الا تغول الاستيطان والاستغفار بكل
الحقوق والمقدسات الدينيه وبالتالي انا
عندما الجا الى عمل قد يراه البعض غير
رشيد فانما لانني
تيقنت من العمل الرشيد لا ياتي ماه ما هو
العمل الرشيد ما اصله نموذج له يعني انا
دائما في هذا الصدد اذكر بواقعه عندما
اتحدث في هذا الموضوع مع طلابي هل نذكر
فيديوهات بورجي مركز التجاره العالمي في
سبتمبر 2001 الم يكن هناك اناس يلقون
بانفسهم من الطابق 26 و28 الناس دي يعمل
كده ليه لانها ايقنت من انه لا جدوى من
البقاء في هذا الموقع وبالتالي نقفز ربما
ينقذنا احد فانا عندما الجا الى عمل من
هذا النوع لاني لم احصل على اي عائد من
الاعمال الاخرى من من المفاوضات او من
المهادات الاخ طيب توقع حضرتك انه العمليه
دائره التطورات سريعه جدا ربما تفاجئنا
واحنا بنتكلم دلوقتي ان العمليه مش بس
تبقى يعني هي اوريدي يعني يعني قاسيه جدا
على اهل غزه لكن ممكن تنفتح جبهه الشمال
مع لبنان ممكن تحدث تطورات كتيره يعني لكن
حتى هذه اللحظه تتوقع حضرتك انه عمليه
طوفان الاقصى يكون تاثيرها ايه على المدى
المتوسط تؤدي الى مثلا
تغيير الوضع القائم تدمير حماس او جماعات
المقاومه ولا ده يمنع جماعات المقاومه قوه
اكبر في التفاوض مع اسرائيل في
المستقبل هو طبعا كما تفضلت حضرتك الامور
ما زالت تتطور طبعا ما حدث حتى الان عمل
جبار في طوفان الاقصى ردت عليه اسرائيل
بقوه تدميريه هائله في قطاع غزه واضح انها
لن تتوقف حتى يعني هم يتحدثون للاسف
المتطرفون او شديد التطرف لان كل معظم
الاسرائيليين متطرفين يتحدثون عن تدمير
غزه واكتشاف حماس ووالى اخره وما اريد ان
اقوله ان ما يحدث ليس يعني ليس من حماس
وانما ما يحدث هو من الشعب الفلسطيني
واكتشاف حماس لن يتم ولن يعني يحدث ان يتم
اجتثاث
للشعب الفلسطيني فالوضع الان ان هناك عمل
جبار فلسطيني قد تم وهناك قدره تدميريه
هائله في قطاع غزه امامنا سيناريوهين اما
ان يتوقف الامر عند هذا الحد او يتم مزيد
من التصعيد هم يتحدثون عن اجتياح بري ا
لغزه طبعا هذه عمليه بالغه ا التعقيد ربما
يلجؤون اليها اذا تصوروا انهم دمروا
البنيه التحتيه للمقاومه في غزه تماما وان
كنت اعتقد ان هذا سيكون قرارا احمق ويعني
سيتكبد فيه خسائر باهظه وربما الاهم ان
حزب الله قال صراحه واعتقد ان احنا تعودنا
انه يعني يلتزم بتصريحاته انه اذا حدث
تدخل
في غزه فسوف يقتحم شمال اسرائيل فهنا
واعلن كده رسميا اعلن كده فاذا نحن امام
سيناريو لتوسيع نطاق الحرب البعض يتحدث عن
تدخل ايران هذا اعتقد مستبعد تماما وانما
توسيع نطاق الحرب في رايي سيتم
باحد يعني باحدى اليتين اما توسيع
نطاق الاعمال معايه لاسرائيل داخل بقيه
الاراضي الفلسطينيه في الضفه مثلا في
الضفه بل وفي داخل اسرائيل
48 هذا احتمال ده هذه هي الاليه
الاولى وهي ممكنه على الاقل في الضفه اه
طبعا وطبعا نذكر في احدى الجولات انها ادت
الى يعني اعمال قام بها
الفلسطينيون المقيمون في اسرائيل منذ
48 الاليه الثانيه هي تدخل حزب الله في
حاله الاجتياح البري لغزه وهنا اذا حدثت
هذه الاليه سيكون هناك توسيع حقيقي لنطاق
ا الحرب وستكون له تداعيات اقليميه واعتقد
ان ساعتها يمكن ان تتصاعد الضغوط الدوليه
من اجل ا وقف ا
القتال في كل
الاحوال هناك نتائج اصبحت في حكم المسلم
بها حكومه اسرائيل
الحاليه انتهى عمرها الافتراضي وهذا واضح
حتى من تصريحات نتنياهو نتنياهو يعرض الان
على المعارضه تكوين حكومه وحده وطنيه ولا
اتصور ان المعارضه يمكن ان تدخل تنضم ال
الحكومه بتشكيلها الحالي لان ما حدث جزء
منه وجود هذه العناصر المتطرفه التي قبل
بها نتنياهو لكي يكون الاغلبيه البرلمانيه
فان انضمت اليه المعارضه التي يتزعم على
بيد او شيء منها لن يحتاجهم وبالتالي انا
اتصور ان اول نتيجه على المدى القصير
ستكون تغيير الحكومه ا الاسرائيليه الاسرا
النتيجه الثانيه الحقيقه احب احب ان
اصيغها في شكل امنيه اني اتصور انه احد
مزايا طوفان الاقصى انه بلور لنا هذا
الموقف الفلسطيني الموحد ا حماس على راس
فصائل مقاومه اخرى قامت بهذا العمل الذي
لم تدنه السلطه الفلسطينيه بل انها قالت
ان من حق الشعب الفلسطيني ان يدافع عن
نفسه اذا انا ارى هذه لحظه تاريخيه لكي
ننجز ما عجزنا عن انجازه منذ 2007 اللي هو
توحد الق كما ان اسرائيل قد تكون حكومه
وحده وطنيه نحن نحتاج حكومه وحده وطنيه
فلسطينيه لانه ان تكونت هذه
الحكومه انا متاكد ان تغييرا نوعيا سيحدث
في المواجهه الفلسطينيه الاسرائيليه يعني
سؤالين اتمنى في اجابه سريعه ثم استاذن
حضرتك لو سمح وقتك نتطرق اليهم بالتفصيل
في حلقات اخرى السؤال الاولاني هل تعتقد
انه اسرائيل يمكن ان تتحمل توابع تدمير او
استئصال ا بكنت يعني حماس من قطاع غزه
ويصبح القطاع بلا اي سلطه
حقيقيه شوف حضرتك تجارب التحرر الوطني
تشير الى الاخفاق التام من قبل السلطات
الاستعماريه في اجتثاث حركات التحرر
الوطني ايا كانت قد تصاب حماس بنكسه مؤقته
انا يعني كتب انتهيت من مقال في بالامس في
الموضوع قلت فيه قد تنجح اسرائيل في ان
تدمر غزه وقد يعني
تستعيد غزه قوتها بعد شهور او بعد سنه او
بعد عقد او بعد اكثر من ذلك ولكن غزه
وفلسطين لن
يخضعا لانه هذه هي خبره التاريخ الزمن
الخاص بالهنود الحمر وابادتهم ولا لانه
هذا تم في ظروف تاريخيه مغايره تماما
لدينا الان 14 مليون فلسطيني موجودين في
على ارضهم وفي الاراضي المجاوره لهم وفي
جميع انحاء العالم الصدفه ده تقريبا قد
عدد اليهود في العالم اللي هم وان اكتست
اسرائيل حماس او غير حماس ماذا ستفعل
بالشعب الفلسطيني لا يوجد سوى حل واحد لما
يجري هو ان تعترف اسرائيل بالحقوق
الفلسطينيه التي يؤسفني ان اقول انها
تقلصت لدرجه لم تعد يعني تمس اسرائيل في
شيء الا اذا كانت تريد ان تبني اسرائيل
الكبرى سواء على اراضي فلسطين او غير
فلسطين السؤال الثاني اللي برض اتمنى
اجابه سريعه الى ان يعني نخصص له حلقات
اخرى في اجابه مختصره جدا تعتقد الان
وطبعا المعطيات بتتغير طوفان الاقصى افاد
ام اضر القضيه على المدى المتوسط والبعيد
افاد افاد كلمه واحده افاد لماذا لانه
اثبت مجددا لان دي ليست المره الاولى
حرب اكتوبر 73 ليست بعيده اثبت مجددا انه
مهما بلغت القوه
الاستعماريه من قوه عسكريه ومن صلافه
سياسيه فان كسرها ممكن امبارح الصحافي
اليساري جدعون ليفي ده بيقول طوفان الاقصى
مزق عباء الغطرسه الاسرائيليه بمناسبه
كلام الدكتور احمد عن جدعون ليفي اذكركم
ان احنا عملنا حلقه عن افكار هذا اليساري
اليهودي الشريف سوف اضع لكم رابتها لتطالع
وها استاذنك في الثلاث اسئله كعناوين نطرح
فيما بعد واحد هل هناك سيناريو تخشاه من
تدفق قد تتعمد اسرائيل لخارج اراضي غزه
عند مصر مثلا وبالتالي تتسع القضيه وتدخل
مصر على خط المواجهه اثنين تاثير طوفان
الاقصى على مواقف في الدول التي طبعت او
التي قد تسعى للتطبيع مع
ا اسرائيل والسؤال الثالث
والاخير هو راي حضرتك فيما قاله عدد من
المفكرين ومنهم عبد الوهاب المسيري انه
اسرائيل اخذه الى زوال ده كلامه كان طبعا
يعني كان محل شك لكن الاحداث الاخيره
بتطرح مره ثانيه هل استاذنك ان الثلاث
اسئله دول ممكن نناقشه في حلقه اخرى
بالاضافه الى مستقبل السلطه الفلسطينيه ان
شاء الله شكرا جزيلا معال الدكتور الشكر
لك يا استاذ سيد وشكرا جزيلا لحضراتكم ومع
الاسئله الاربعه الاخيره ان شاء الله يكون
لنا حلقات اخرى مع الاستاذ الدكتور احمد
يوسف اشكركم والى اللقاء